you play presidents in lots of sketches  before but what are the sort of  challenges are playing FDR in a feature  film well there was a script that you  had to live up to a very good script so  you had to had to do your best of course  there were some really good actors that  you had to you know serve and you know  had to walk around with these braces on  it was over I was uncomfortable and sort  of inhibiting your body so you had to  really be in your body while it was  tortured a little bit I tried to I tried  to absorb his voice and and not do it as  an impression but just have it as in a  sort of a natural way I tried to hit up  brilliant smile and he had a way of  engaging people and in getting them to  to feel appreciated and he was a  politician a great politician so I tried  to think about how he would deal with  his personal life in a way that would  get things done while acknowledging  everyone's point of view  you